Breaking bad is definitely a landmark in TV history,
to someone who grew up watching the serials of the 1960s.
A show with that level of technical Infomatic complexity would be somewhat
surprising.
There's no doubt that television as an art form has grown and improved over time
through continuous experimentation with the format breaking bad,
didn't come out of nowhere. Vince Gilligan and the writers of breaking bad,
built on the work of the great shows before them to make something that took
full advantage of what makes television unique since its inception,
the rules of television,
forced producers to adapt to the unusual nature of the format. Unlike movies,
TV competed directly with other shows.
Changing your mind was as easy as pressing a button borrowing techniques from
serial and radio TV writers fought for the attention of viewers in a way movies
didn't have to early TV show runners used cliffhangers to ensure viewers kept
coming back to a piece shorter attention spans.
Every show had its own contained episodic narrative structure.
Sure. To meet with us again next week at the same time.
It's breaking bad.
So groundbreaking in particular is how it took the constraints of the format and
use them to its advantage.
Cliffhangers became an opportunity for the show to reflect groundbreaking
character changes and episodic narrative structure means that the show is rich
with short stories that stick with the viewers and deepen our understanding of
the characters.
Many episodes are self-contained stories that don't directly move the plot
forward,
but give us insight into character dynamics and indirectly raise the stakes for
the show as a whole
Importantly, breaking bad took full advantage of the most important asset.
Television has time while Michael Corleone went from an unassuming idealist to
murderous gangster. It almost seems like his destiny.
He was part of the family after all Walter White, however,
had much further to fall.
The medium of television gave the creators the time necessary for Walt's
dramatic change. By the final season,
longtime fans of the series had spent years of their lives invested in Walter
White's transformation from Mr. Rogers to Scarface the entire series built up so
much tension that the catharsis of finishing the series is virtually
unparalleled in most other popular entertainment.
The point is breaking bad was great because it understood how to use the medium
it was written in and the same goes for any other format like the early TV
viewers of the 1950s, we are living in the early years of a new medium,
but instead of the medium of television, ours is the internet though.
Some may not look at the creation of internet content as much of an artistic
endeavor.
Online creators are nonetheless making similar creative decisions about their
cinematography editing and even narrative structure based around the medium.
Some are cleverly harnessing these constraints and using them to their
advantage.
By now you have received my message that we will no longer be communicating.
Television.
The internet as a medium gave way to a new set of creative challenges for the
first time,
the medium itself gave the consumer the same level of access and distribution as
preferred.
National creators.
What he has is an internet connection and a crappy camera from Walmart.
And that should be enough. And I think right, because of technology.
For the first time ever, that is enough.
Internet creators,
don't just compete with each other like television does with other shows,
people producing content on the internet,
also compete with a consumer's own friends and family.
This distinction has shaped the style and format of internet content.
The relationship that young people have with content that they see online,
that they choose to watch versus the content that they see on TV, which is fed.
What's up guys, welcome back to do it with clothes on.
When you think of video content on the internet,
chances are you think of blocking. And that makes sense.
Blocking is essentially Instagram come to life.
Snappily edited visually engaging videos that show off lavish and over the top
lifestyles though, the format is intentionally informal.
These creators definitely make careful aesthetic and thematic choices to convey
a sense of authenticity. The genre has some obvious and cliche tropes,
handheld cameras talking directly into the screen,
little to no color correction and day in the life.
Storytelling have become creative choices.
These filmmakers use this aesthetic style originated from a place of
technological limitation, but with the cheaper and better technology,
the practical constraints are no longer there.
Flockers like David doebrick have the budget and equipment to shoot their blogs
like a traditional documentary or reality television show, but they don't.
And that's because they know that the vlog format plays to the strengths of the
media on the internet content creators compete with their audiences,
own family and friends.
They keep the authenticity and the lack of Polish to make their content fit in.
Well, amongst the Instagram stories of the family and friends,
you actually know Dover is a great example of someone who has really captured
the style. His blogs are flashily edited and focus on a lavish lifestyle,
but at the end of the day,
they rely on the authenticity of a group of friends having fun.
His episodes feature a wide ranging cast of characters each with a particular
brand. Domus a player. Jason is old and Josh is a washed up actor.
This semi scripted format combined with the authentic feeling vlog aesthetic
blurs the line between staged moments and re.
Clickbait clickbait. My God quick, get a thumbnail.
No matter how ridiculous the scenario,
Dover has a real knack for making content that feels like a day spent hanging
out with your friends.
So it's no surprise that he's so popular on a medium that values social networks
blocks like these are successful. Not just because they feel real,
but because they are hyper real, his flocks channel,
the innate desire people have on the internet to edit and craft their own online
image to mimic the seemingly fun and carefree life of doebrick and his friends.
Yet,
it's always crucial that these blogs don't feel too produced and amateur quality
maintains that authentic informal feel.
And this informality does not just exist in flogging.
It's also popular in other genres of internet content.
I'm sorry. I'm sorry. It's okay. Listen,
this is what we want to give you an opportunity to communicate.
A great example of a format that could only succeed on the internet is the long
form interview podcast.
While this interview format definitely borrows from traditional radio shows like
the Joe Rogan experience capitalize on the,
at your own pace nature of the internet to a topic more fully.
You can see in maybe like an interview that isn't great that like that person
doing the interview is just leaving a lot of change on the table.
Like maybe they'll like ask something,
but because they're just thinking about the next question. And because like,
this is just some sort of formula,
like they're not really looking at the guests.
Thanks Hawaiian. We have to talk about this pineapple jumper.
Suit and what we do. Wow.
Broken and other podcast hosts present their interviews,
not as formalized interviews, but as conversations.
The advantage of this style is that guests relax and often say and do things
they wouldn't normally do.
I think when I was, I don't know, five or six or something,
I thought I was insane.
Ideas get flushed out and we get a seemingly more honest to look at the
interviewee. It's nothing like the traditional talk show.
You can kind of see,
like maybe they kind of wanted that topic to be explored a little bit deeper.
But it's important to remember that this style is still an interview tactic
while it seems unproduced and unpolished.
It's no doubt a conscious decision on Rogan's part to elicit a specific reaction
out of his guests.
This informality authenticity and on-demand availability makes these shows
perfectly suited for the internet.
Their success makes sense on a medium where people expect transparency and love
discussion self-expression and personality thrive in the podcast format and on
the internet in general,
people on the internet simultaneously play a character and to act like
themselves.
These podcasts further blur that line while vlogs capitalize on the image making
of the internet and podcasts capitalize on.
Self-expression a third genre capitalizes on another equally important part of
the internet.
Hey, everybody. Welcome back to another episode of Kickstarter cramp. Hey,
little stinkers, and welcome back to youtube.com. What's up Greg.
Welcome back to my channel here. Beautiful bastion.
They'll be on a fantastic Tuesday. Welcome back to the Philip de Franco show.
Commentary.
Channels are another genre, unique to YouTube and to internet content,
whether they're political, humorous or dramatic,
they all take advantage of the medium in a similar way.
Like floggers commentary channels speak directly to the camera as a way to
incorporate their viewer into the broader conversation channels.
Like I dubs H three H three, drew Gooden,
and many others engage in pre-existing discussion about news or internet
content. If a podcast is like a social media post and flogs,
or like somebody's profile, then commentary channels are the comments. Section.
These channels constantly respond to each other, highlighting content.
They find problematic and engaging in a level of meta commentary that often
requires a lot of existing knowledge on the topic.
It makes sense that content responsive to audience discussion became so popular
on the internet. Television shows on NBC. Don't have a comment section,
but internet content creators are constantly bombarded with comments and
opinions.
Today. Guys,
I am reacting to perhaps the most requested video of all time.
As a result, creators often take that feedback and change their discussions.
The highly discursive nature of the internet has allowed content creators to
enhance their content by being a part of the feedback loop smart creators,
use this feedback loop to incorporate their audience into their content,
giving them an almost personal stake in the story.
They'll flogging podcasts and commentary channels all vary drastically in style.
They all understand the constraints of the internet and leverage those
constraints to tell a more thematic and engaging story.
So what does the future hold for internet content who is telling a story that
pushes the boundaries of what the internet can do?
What will be the breaking bad of the internet? Of course only time will tell,
but I think there is one creator who takes advantage of all the strengths of
internet content.
Shane Dawson.
Industry news. We should talk about Shane Dawson. Shane.
Dawson is the King of YouTube.
Shane Dawson, Shane Bolson.
Shane Dawson is doing a documentary on Logan Paul's brother, Jake Paul.
Okay. In the past year,
Shane Dawson has definitely challenged our assumptions of what internet content
can be. These whole documentary and series have just been over the,
over the top.
Amazing to see that this has become kind of a site-wide event.
It's the mind of Jake Paul, like all of it,
which is weird because YouTube drama, not a big part of my life,
but I was interested in this because it looks like we're living in a time where
the entertainment of YouTube starting to become more, less.
Shane's long form documentaries on controversial YouTubers and conspiracy
theories get as many views as primetime television shows in a space that's so
diverse and fragmented. The videos seem to unify the commission.
But as of recording this video, it's at 7.8 million views.
It's such a big site-wide event.
We usually see a drop in the number of people watching our video during the
first two to three hours of release of a Shane Dawson video.
These videos, Shane Dawson, borrows, the techniques of commentary channels,
law informed podcasts, and the flock to tell his story like commentary channels.
Shane saw the cultural relevance of this topic and seized the opportunity by
entering something ongoing and incredibly popular.
The docu-series was thrust to the forefront of internet culture.
Not only did he enter and provide his own take on the discussion,
he went to the source himself creating perhaps the most complete and valuable
entry into the discussion.
Shane actively participated and even edited later episodes to respond to
up-to-date criticism because Shane is not just releasing a finished eight part
series, he's editing it and adapting it in real time.
Based on the response from the community and the community is responding to his
response. And it's a self-fulfilling cycle that never ends.
This technique invested the viewer in the production of these videos and this
participatory storytelling suits the internet perfectly.
Then in another bowl decision on Shane's part,
he decided to make the series extremely long form an eight part series totalling
about seven hours of content on a platform known for short snappy videos.
This change gave him the time to delve into the matter thoroughly.
The informal one camera's set up coupled with the fact that he kept roughly one
interview per episode,
kept his interviewees relaxed much like how people feel on the Joe Rogan
experience while his conversations were no doubt edited. The internet,
allowed him to slow down the conversation and have a full picture of the
situation, providing many different perspectives. Finally, most importantly,
he intentionally filmed using vlog aesthetics and editing that capture the
advantages of the medium. By speaking at the viewer,
Shane engages the YouTube community in a very YouTube specific way.
It seems only fitting to investigate Paul using Paul's own.
Format. Yeah, cause I'm normally the one with the camera.
The blog aesthetic gave that same friendly feel.
We get from internet creators like David doebrick, the format stays the same,
but their lives get stripped of much of the glamour. Silence is not cut out.
The camera is less frantic and the subject matter is much heavier.
Shane picks apart that seemingly authentic flocking style of David doebrick and
Jake Paul, and exposes how scripted and stale those lifestyles can actually.
Pretty much everyone that's a little bit older knows
that it's all fake.
In doing so. He ironically creates something even more authentic, a story,
even more suited for the internet.
The reason the series had so much authority and worked so well was because Shane
produced it so authentically at its core, it was about understanding a person.
And what better way to do that then as friends hanging out and having fun
together, Shane series might be the first of its kind.
I certainly can't think of a vlog series. That's not only so widely popular,
but both this level of technical and thematic complexity,
Shane Dawson has done so well on YouTube because he understands the stories,
the internet thrives on and the techniques necessary to tell them.
So maybe you're looking at something like Shane's flog through the lens of the
medium explains why this series was so popular when it came out and maybe like
the writers of breaking bad.
Shane captured how to use his medium to craft a message,
or maybe the format of internet entertainment still has a long, long way to go.
And people are going to get sick of some guy online telling you what to think,
but I sure.
Hope not.
One of the many benefits of the medium of the internet is its accessibility.
The drawback is that it's almost as easy to make low quality content on the
internet as it is to consume it. When it comes to something like video editing.
I don't want to waste time trying to decide what content is worth learning from.
If I'm going to learn a new editing software,
I would enroll in a high quality and efficient editing tutorial online like the
Adobe premier beginner's course on Skillshare Skillshare has over 20,000 high
quality classes on many topics ranging from editing to creative writing.
The first 500 people to click on the link in the description will get two months
of completely free access to Skillshare that's editing tutorials,
plus thousands of others from marketing and video editing to photography.
Thanks for watching and a big thank you to Skillshare for sponsoring this video.
Yeah.